pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux j'ai reçu une lettre de monsieur
von krockow vendent cran vraiment
certaines personnes ont un nom à coucher
dehors mais quel rapport entre le
patronyme et nuit passée sous les ponts
à la belle étoile
cette expression remonte au moyen âge à
l'époque elle les campagnes et les rues
étaient souvent mal famés les agressions
étaient fréquentes
aussi les aubergistes était-il très
méfiant dès que la nuit tombait les
portes étaient fermées à double tour
quand un client se présentait il devait
alors décliné son identité à travers le
judas
si son nom n'avait pas une consonance
locale la porte lui restait fermé il
passé la nuit à la belle étoile à cause
de son nom à coucher dehors
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]